hey what's up guys my name is jenna and
welcome to episode 18 of the sparky game
engine series in which we make a
beautiful game engine from scratch in c
plus plus so last time
last time we talked about arrays of
textures and how we could get multiple
textures on the screen there are a few
things that are kind of annoying with
that such as how these text ids are just
floating around but we're going to cover
that not this episode we're going to
basically defer that and cover that
um probably in the in episode 20 which
will be the maintenance episode and
we'll basically fix all that stuff and i
don't really want to put that
into um
into uh this episode but this episode is
the beginning of something very exciting
because we're going to be implementing
font rendering so font rendering is a
difficult task okay don't don't let it
fool you font rendering is not an easy
task
um
and
we're going to do it in the next two
episodes hopefully so this episode will
be all about getting certain libraries
to work and then the next episode is
going to be about um actually getting
font rendering to work so what i'll do
right now is i'm going to open mischief
and i'm going to give you a lecture on
how this is going to work and hopefully
um i will discover how it's going to
work as well in the process and my thing
is unplugged
let me just plug in my drawing pad
to my
graphics tablet as the pros are calling
it
um okay so here's here's the plan um we
want to get font onto the screen that is
pretty
uh that is pretty um
i guess apparent
so
this isn't a very good tablet so it's
gonna be difficult to write but anyway
font rendering um
so
that's the master plan
um
what we want to do is we want to
basically the way font rendering works
is we have a ttf
file right a true type font if you will
and this ttf file is basically our font
okay and it's got a bunch of glyphs
which define
basically the mathematics behind how
characters appear based on the font that
we're currently looking at right
we need to take those glyphs we need to
basically render a glyph that is
appropriate to the font size
that we choose okay
and that glyph needs to be put onto a
texture okay
when we want to draw the character f for
example on the screen we need to
make a vertex buffer okay so we need to
make basically a piece of geometry
that is the correct size
of the character so for something like w
it'll be
this
it'll be like that for example
but for something like say l it'll be
like that so they're different sizes and
of course depends on how big the
character is as well so we need to
dynamically be able to construct all
these vertices um for for a certain
object we need to be able to um apply a
texture to it
and render it onto the screen usually
you would get something like this
rendering on a certain channel
so because obviously the way that when
you're actually making the font
um
you don't like the color information
isn't stored in the texture you do that
by the shader so you might have
something like the actual outline or the
actual like texture itself being stored
in one color channel usually the alpha
channel sometimes something like the red
channel it doesn't really matter uh
different libraries do it differently
but
the idea is you have that in your shader
and you can do whatever you want with it
and there's your um texture now it would
be incredibly inefficient if i wanted to
write the word hello and i had to use
one two three four five draw calls
so five draw calls
with five different textures so what
usually happens is you want to make one
texture one huge texture like a texture
atlas or a sprite sheet
which essentially has all of these
characters
um
well kind of packed together say like
that and then it's like oh you're
rendering the letter e i want to
retrieve
i want to use these texture coordinates
and then i want to use these texture
coordinates for o and oh you're
rendering like
uh an l i want to use these texture
coordinates and whatnot but the point is
it generates this um this texture atlas
or
font sheet or sprite sheet or there's so
many different
um
ways to um
name it but that's the idea right so you
don't want to and then you want to just
bind that one texture and that one
texture is kind of your font texture so
you might have an aerial texture okay
that's assuming that it fits you can
make these random size you can make
these varying sizes for example 512 by
512 is usually a pretty
um normal size to make it for example
and that would fit a lot of characters
um
but that's kind of the idea and once you
generate the character once it's in that
texture it's in your video memory all it
has to do is bind that texture
right just gl bind texture right and
and pass along to the vertex buffer to
our renderer the appropriate information
such as these are the vertex positions
yeah uh indices it knows because it's
going to be
all these are going to be square that
are going to be some weird shape like
that they're all going to be square
uh not square sorry rectangle uh
rectangular
um and then it has to have basically
yeah so it just needs
vertex positions and texture coordinates
and that's it okay
um that's really all we need and then
you can you could probably pass it along
a color to the shader if you want you
can uniform that as well
it'd be probably be much more
appropriate to pass it um via an
attribute though so that's that's kind
of the idea okay um
uh
now of course if you're dealing with
mono spaced fonts for example the job is
much easier so something like korean u
or
gonzalez or really there's a lot right
any monospace font of course has the
name monospace because it has the same
spacing the other thing you have to deal
with by the way isn't just something
like
um
i don't know
let's just say um
if you're if you're yeah so if i'm
rendering a font that isn't mono spaced
i have to deal with the spacing between
characters as well okay and there's
different terms such as kerning and
whatnot i'm not going to use any fancy
terms
uh in this video basically because i
just don't know them 100
um
but uh you need to decide the spacing
between characters you can see that
these l's have like no spacing and then
something like an o might have more and
it the actual geometry will be wider
than it and whatnot obviously if you
have um a mono-spaced font everything
will be
kind of the same they'll have the same
kind of spacing okay that makes your job
much easier okay because you don't need
to deal with stuff like oh what's the
difference what's the distance there the
other problem of course there's other
problems if you have something like an h
and an e great example um this obviously
is this big this is this big so how do
you get them aligned you know
if you just render them normally you
might render them like that
okay that's going to look weird so you
need to know this spacing as well from
the top of this
there's so many different different
problems with this okay which is why we
have libraries such as free type and a
little kind of helper library that we'll
also use
um so yeah so basically let's just talk
about the technology that we'll use
so we'll be using something called free
type free type is incredibly popular
okay free type is used by
um i'm pretty sure it's used by ios and
android as well so like it's it's big
right it's not like some little project
thing it's pretty huge it's used by a
lot of operating systems and games and
whatnot to get um
font rendering to work um but
essentially what free type does is it
deals with
taking in files and outputting textures
okay
um i should probably just google it and
show you
um
exactly what it does
and sorry i shouldn't say it i shouldn't
say it outputs textures because it
doesn't really do that it
it isn't api specific so it's not tied
to something like opengl so yes it's
used by ios and android as well as uh
versions of linux and whatnot
but i should say that um
yes it's a font engine uh
which um yeah so it'll produce glyph
images rather than
textures
um but it will do that from uh
from glyphs essentially and from stuff
like true type fonts right it doesn't
only suppose so uh support ttf obviously
okay that's just i mentioned that
because it's a very popular font format
um it supports a variety of fonts and it
gives us these uh so from a given glyph
outline which is what you would get from
something like a ttf file
um
you would uh
as you can see it's capable of producing
a high quality monochrome bitmap okay so
it basically takes a glyph and it
renders it onto a bitmap okay so um and
again monochrome because the coloring
and whatnot will be set ourselves so
once we get this bitmap and a bitmap is
literally what it sounds like it's just
a bunch of pixels right once we get the
bitmap we want to use we want to
basically pop it into a texture atlas
okay so to do that we could write our
own crazy texture packing algorithm
which
is completely unnecessary and would take
ages so instead we're going to use
another library called free type
gl now free type gl is
a little library at least we're going to
make it little because we're going to
strip it down a lot we don't really need
most of what it offers
but we do need its texture packing code
and it's glyph generation code and all
of that stuff click generation obviously
will be done by free type but you know
what i mean lift handling code
and we're going to basically extract all
the useful parts from it so we're going
to basically download both of these
libraries make them work together and
compile them ourselves and actually put
them into sparky core because again we
want them script and to take them and
compile them so that we can run sparky
on the web and it can handle its own
font rendering okay one thing i want to
mention quickly about m scriptin
is um and how stuff is going to work and
scripting is
i have mentioned this in i believe the
sparky intro video but it has been a
while since i mentioned emscripton so m
scriptin is a an llvm2
uh javascript compiler so basically it
will take your c plus loss code and
compile it into javascript okay so
button yes
i guess it will also take opengl and
convert it into
using its little glaz emulator from gel
embedded systems emulator it will
convert it into webgl as well so
basically it's going to take a c plus
plus open gel application and give it
and put it into a javascript webgl
application because it does that um we
can get sparky on the web and if you're
concerned about what is this weird thing
that nobody uses
unity uses it so a lot of unreal uses it
like a lot of game engines that have
that happen to work on the web use m
script and for that so is it it works it
works surprisingly well i have to say
simpleplus.javascript you might be like
this is probably very broken and very
limited it's not it works very very well
okay in fact right now if you go to
churno.best
um and yes i did register that domain
name um you'll see that this is a sparky
webgl rendering over over 50 over 50 000
sprites i think it's 56 thousand
700 or something sprites at well i sold
16 it's being v-synced so
look at that it's and this this was like
this required very minimal adjustment as
well so
chennai.best uh is a great example of so
this is powered by ms krypton so anyway
m scription works that's that's kind of
what i'm getting at so because m
scripting works um
what needs to happen is obviously if we
have something like a dll or a static
lib right a static library um that's
basically already generated kind of
machine code it's not something that
encryption can compile
um
which means that if we want something to
be included in the compilation into m
scriptin and popped into sparky core so
that it can use it as javascript
it basically needs to be
source right
because of that
we can't really grab free type and free
type gl and compile them into their own
libraries which is what i would which is
what i would have done
if we weren't using m script and so if
we didn't care about web if we were just
making this work on um
you know desktop operating systems such
as windows mac and linux
i wouldn't worry about um
i wouldn't worry about uh
you know having to i don't know i would
basically just compile it into a dll and
a lib if it was on windows for example
right so i would be compiling it into a
library
since we are on unscripted we actually
need inscription to basically still see
the source code so what we're going to
do is we're going to grab free type and
free type gl's source code we're going
to put them right into sparky core
probably into its own folder called
something like ext which stands for
external or api or something like
dependency i don't know i haven't
thought of a folder name yet but we'll
put we'll pop all of our stuff probably
into a folder which i'll call ext um and
that'll be all the external frameworks
that we have but we happen to have the
source code because we need them for em
scripting okay otherwise it would be
much better and much more organized to
just generate a either a dynamic or a
static library right
that would be the optimal situation but
since we're dealing with unscripted we
can't do that now
what about free image for example right
we uh we didn't compile free image at
all we just got a dynamic library okay
for it
is it going to work without scripting no
okay if we wanted to make free image
work with ms scriptin we could download
its source code again put it into this
ext fold that we'll make and compile it
through um sparky and then you know
throw the script in and whatnot
now we're not going to do that because
um keep in mind that we are using
javascript okay so if we're in m
scripted land so if we're not in desktop
land if we're on em script and land we
can use javascript because emscripten
compiles it into javascript so we can so
keep in mind that if you're targeting
the web and you're suddenly like oh how
is this gonna work inside a web browser
don't worry you can just write
javascript code to make it do it for you
so what i mean by that is stuff like
image loading and particularly basically
any kind of asset loading
and management we can actually just
write in plain javascript inside our c
plus plus source okay via em scriptin
um and we can just simply get javascript
to do that stuff for us so we could
um when we when we move on to audio for
example we're not going to we're just
going to get javascript to load and play
audio for us
if we're on the web okay that it's as
simple as that that simplifies our job
tremendously now the question is why
don't we just get javascript and css and
html and whatnot to just render fonts
for us
like why not if we're on if we're on um
if we're on the web why not generate a
dll or a lib right
put and just use only that if we're on
desktop and if we're on the web get
javascript to do that for us
that has its limitations okay if we get
javascript to do our phone rendering for
us first of all sparky's no is certainly
not really aware of what's going on it's
not really treated as an engine like
piece of geometry it's not handled by
the engine it's handled by the browser
but
more specifically it means that we can't
use things like shaders with our fonts
okay so we might want some crazy effects
so we might want uh i don't know we just
might want to run a certain shader for a
font we want we probably want to have
that customization available to us we
might want to do
crazy things in opengl it just it's just
better for our font to actually be part
of our engine okay because that way it's
guaranteed to look the same on pretty
much all systems okay
um and it's not something that we need
to just worry about javascript about
okay
um
that's kind of the plan now of course if
you do render a font in javascript is
that it is actually possible to render
it to a bitmap and pass it through m
script and back to c plus plus that is
insane and you shouldn't do that if
there's just a simple
uh semi i should say semi simple
solution of just getting free type and
free type gl to be compiled inside our
ext um folder and whatnot and just be
part of our project okay so that's the
idea that's how font rendering is going
to work so we are making it universal
we're going to write it once and it's
going to run everywhere um well mostly
most places um
right once run most places that's
sparky um but that's the idea okay so
let's begin um let's go back here
because this is where we were and this
is the free type
um
uh website click on download 2.5.5 i
believe is the latest version so let's
just look for that so save under stable
releases if we look at 2.5.5
we'll see a tar and a gz
archive we'll download that we'll wait
for that to download and we'll just open
that up and i'm going to um just go
ahead and in documents libs i'm going to
make a new folder called free type just
temporarily so that we can extract these
things and of course i'm just going to
go ahead and basically just grab free
type and
probably yeah 2.555 let's just grab it
and extract it here okay cool
so we've got free type let's focus with
free type first and then we'll move on
to free type gl so we'll set up free
type and free type gl make sure they're
compiling perfectly
um
in our um
thing right um
inside our sparky engine
and then we will um
once that all is set up we'll end the
episode there and episode 19 which is
the next episode will actually
render a font onto the screen okay
because that requires a lot of setup as
well to get it to work without batch
renderer and whatnot okay cool so we've
got a few things here now the best thing
to do and again if i was if i was
doing this just for desktop and i just
wanted a dll or a lib i wanted a dynamic
or a static library i would go into
the builds into windows into visual uh c
2010 i would open the solution and i
would compile it okay i would do that
that's what i would do in fact i'm
actually going to open this up so that
we can largely copy what it's doing
so uh yes we'll open that we'll probably
have to convert it that's fine
you'll notice that if you open up free
type
the visual studio solution
um you'll probably notice that there are
a few different um
uh
build configurations right you pretty
much want to use release multi-threaded
okay that's probably the best one to use
um for win32 as well um
we probably want to look at the
configuration for release multithreaded
and just make sure that we're pretty
much compiling that um again this would
be beautiful as you can see it's
compiling into a static library that's
fantastic we could totally just use that
as doing all this cool stuff um
let's just look at the preprocessor
because that's probably going to be
important
so
yeah so build library we don't want
win32 and debug
we probably want to grab most of these
preprocessor definitions when we
actually put it into our thing so that
we can pile it properly
um
we'll leave this open and we'll refer to
it so if we go back into uh sparky okay
i'll make a um if i just open
uh
if i just open this in file explorer
i'll grab
um
if we go out here we probably source
looks
about
right so i don't actually even know what
we need see that's this is the problem
like i haven't again i haven't actually
looked at free type and
what we actually need but it looks like
it looks like we don't need too much so
if we look at all files measure them and
just
look at the ones that are actually
included in the project
yeah this is this is apparently like all
we need okay so
um
where where is this
at these files at it's open containing
folder source base so base um i'm
guessing most of these are in base
because there's a lot of different like
i don't even know if we need the modules
necessarily
um
let's just open this that's
in
okay
see most of these aren't even here
which makes this a bit annoying
so bitmap that sounds important
that's in base as well
we'll try and grab bass i don't think
we'll need there's a lot of stuff here i
don't think we'll need
most of it so i'm just going to grab
bass okay um so it's in free type source
bass so i'll
go ahead and
go back to sparky core i'll make a
folder called ext which is all of our
external libraries that we'll use
i'll
make a folder called free type and i'll
paste in base over here okay
or in fact i can just paste in like
source because i just want to keep that
kind of situation okay so back in sparky
core i'll just see the refresh button
uh ext i'm going to include in project
and this should include all of our
um all about fun code here
um we'll get rid of say jam file and
rules
uh
yes uh these are just c files these have
no headers whatsoever let's go back into
here
so that was bass right
let me copy all the bass no these should
have headers they do have s okay cool so
there's bass
all right a lot of this stuff is
probably going to yell at us um ftg ft2
build it needs
again i have no idea how to build this
so we're going to just this could take a
while it shouldn't but it could and it
could be incorrect as well include that
sounds important let's go let's grab
that so i'll grab include
and i'll pop that into uh free type and
then include
now
i'm guessing that include in free type
is going to be something that it
probably wants to have as
i'll probably just pop out pop out into
all configurations and
um into here and i'll just add in
um
let's
see um
i'll add in
so our solution directory
um
nice will be in project directory
project directory um xt
free type
include
so this should make that go away
um what is that that's probably not even
defined anywhere okay so we need to find
out things like this um intellisense is
going to go mad that's all right though
we haven't tried building it yet so we
don't have any real errors
uh let's go out here so where are these
defined
let's define an internal domain okay
um is this just including internal that
sounds important
so this in source internal is that a
thing no
where is this at where's internal
internals in include internal
okay
cool so
um
include internal
where's this this is defined inside
internal as well
so is internal included here is does
that include internal
does that include internal
uh not exactly yes it does so there it
is it includes that so that should be
there right
top out here
uh let's open that
open that
okay so here we go um okay so
build library
that's why so it's not including it
because that's not enabled so how do we
not build it as a library per se how do
we just
how do we just use it
where the where the headers
let's refresh this
let's include this in project as well
okay so
um
so include internal headers definitions
from internal only when building the
library so what if i'm not building a
library
because i'm assuming i don't want that i
could just define the macro but yeah
i doubt i doubt that's what it wants me
to do so
so yeah
that should still be defined though
that should be defined as like
nothing or something
huh i'm saying nothing
no um
yeah
okay well let's just build this and
we'll deal with the actual errors
all 74 of them
yes so that's not defined
oh
i might just have to google this there
might be a macro that you can pass that
uh
build
because it doesn't seem to be an
alternative which is very weird it's
very suspicious
okay build free type not as a library is
what i'm kind of googling
um
wow this is kind of annoying
okay
hmm
hmm
internal
that sounds that sounds internal
yeah so all of these are just from
macros
i don't know let's um
i guess we'll try building it as a
library and see what happens so i'll go
back here and i will look at the
preprocessor
definition for release multi-threaded
i'm going to basically just
okay so we've already got that ft ftg
build library let's grab that
all configurations
preprocessor
that
we probably want
we probably want all these as
well okay okay so that should make most
of the errors go away we'll see if this
builds
um okay we got one error and i just
can't include this where's that from ft
mac see that
i'm very surprised that that actually
built though
surely there was a macro that
doesn't build that
um
that's very odd
this shouldn't this should
there should be a macro that doesn't do
this
well there is because you can see that
that but why does it do this part
what
look i
i don't know i
i don't know
it's look it sounds very bizarre to me
why you would include mac only stuff
um
okay so now we're even worse
handle what's that from
um
yes let's one thing we should do is
actually get rid of um oh no what
happened to cancel
no
okay um
we'll get rid of this because that will
be added automatically on a release
build
um
which let's just see what happens here
okay
so
okay great
so what was this
that's still mac
why why is this even being considered
include this file after free type uh and
after any mac specific headers
okay but
why is it being why is it a thing
that's very bizarre
so ft mac
ft mac is well seems to be probably the
only problem
lol i don't know
let's find the uh where is ft mac
i i'm incredibly confused
and i have no idea why
this is
a thing
um
but it is so
okay this looks successful
oh it's not um okay
that's okay
oh
so linking didn't work out because empty
bass
yeah it looks like it's just compiling
multiple things again
this is not fun
win32
see this is annoying this um
this is annoying
um
okay
okay that's the free type header
which has everything i think
i could just um
what are those app files
okay so let's look for um
all the hash includes that we have in
free type
because apparently um
why it's including this so many times
that's our stuff
free type
this is great
okay let's see what this is including
three types of h internal stuff
let's just check this out real quick
ah
just stop being annoying
look at all these freaking includes
just give me that file
don't make me manually go there
oh i'm manually going there
um yeah
i mean it's got a header guards and
everything
but apparently i've heard the free type
includes
c files
so
that's annoying but okay
hmm
look at this look at this
look at this
look at this stuff okay let's build it
again i guess we'll
we'll see so ft bass
uh has oh my goodness
what is it ft get advances
was it implemented it's implemented here
so
the only way this could be happening is
if c files are actually being included
in
places which would be extremely weird
and unfortunate
so ft bass is trying to compile oh this
is going to be so annoying i wanted this
i wanted this to be straightforward but
just say
okay
let's just
oh
oh look
goodbye
i guess i should comment that out
this should already be much better
yes it's nine down without 19 errors
um what is this what is this what is
this ah see this is exactly what i was
i was fearing
and there's probably another file that
does that unfortunately
because free type just thinks it's the
best idea on the planet
to include c files
uh something else has to do it
ah let's just look at this that's not
gonna help us at all so ft unit can't
okay let's just find ft in it um
where is it ft init
dot c what does that include
this shouldn't be too difficult because
there's apparently just one file left so
it's one of these things one of these
puppies includes
um
includes naughty things
let's define
okay well it's got to be one of these
okay we've got there we got those
oh here we go
let's just leave this here for now i'll
put on my other monitor
um where was that
let's md5.c here it is okay that's
macron out
let's look for more things
so we've gone through all these i
believe
let's just ah this is a bit annoying
let's just pop this like right here for
now
um
okay uh yes so this is gone maybe
where what is it doing
show me where that is no okay let me
just re-look for this stuff
i'll just search for include
okay uh all good in the hood
i'm looking for stuff that ends in c
because it shouldn't
okay this stuff we got rid of
yeah
okay that's fine
uh there was another one
here that one
where's that one
okay that's macroed out
we know it has something to do with ft
init which isn't going to really help us
at all
dot c dot c dot c dot c
almost at the end
this is like our stuff
annoying oh look at this stuff
um
this is so annoying
can i just search for things that end in
c
how do i regular expression
i
honestly don't know how to regular
expression
um
oh
yeah screw that
don't see that should be good enough
right
oh that's ridiculous
oh okay so
i should have looked at the error
messages more closely because if i did i
wouldn't realize that they're actually
unresolved symbols not um
not other stuff so where's this in this
is an ft init what does that do exactly
it might it's probably something that we
just don't have
either that or we can pop into here real
quick and take a look at um release
multi-threaded linker input
isn't a thing um obviously
because it's a static lib but
um
what does it want when f and d drive
yeah this looks like um
it was like windows stuff
um
windows font driver class
these are things that we actually need
where do they exist
hmm
i'm looking at this right now as well
over here i don't know how much i'll
find i don't know what this is windows
font driver class is what it looks like
but
a free type saw screen font let's see
that's a thing apparently it's a free
type thing
oh
oh i know why
i probably didn't have wind fonts
is that that look that's probably
important
let's copy that
um
let's put that in source and win fonts
ah let's
include
that
let's get rid of this stuff
let's rebuild them
it's still annoying
oh no but that one's gone
oh that's gonna be annoying um yes
this is gonna be annoying
let's
do this let's go into sublime text
and hop into
free types source and then for all
uh let's go out open folders
we'll look for the stuff we need
so
t42 driver class
um
looks like it's in type 42 so let's grab
type 42
this is the joy of compiling stuff
yourself with no help by the way hope
everyone is in is having as much fun as
i am
uh it should be significantly easier to
compile a free type gl though so don't
you worry
okay um
cff
no
i should have probably well i should see
if i drive a class
cff
predictably
oh that's a lot of stuff that we're
missing
looks like free time's not as simple as
i thought it was
okay morrow's yeah um we need a lot of
stuff done oh that's already defined oh
doesn't matter we'll solve the
unresolved stuff first pcf and t1 as
well i know we need t1 but
pc okay so pcf and t1 we need a lot of
stuff
t1 type 1 and pcf i'm going to assume we
both we need that
it's all right
we're building stuff
slowly
um
type 1 pcf include
expand that get rid of stuff we don't
need
emscription is going to have so much fun
compiling this i can just [ __ ] i can
just feel it
also the get repository is about to
explode with more code
um
ft stream oh this is i should probably
just do everything shouldn't i
ft stream
that's in
not there
are these oh let's just let's get rid of
this
where are my ft streams at
cid
that's not it
bdf ah we probably need all these
modules
i don't really want to buy all of them
though
because i i feel like
should we just do it should we just do
everything
oh there's just so much though
it does all look important i'll i'll
copy stuff i think looks important
so most of things
should have done this all right it
doesn't matter we'll grab like freaking
everything whoa i need to do that
windows calm down
yeah er to be honest in retrospect
everything looks important
except for like tools
i think already got pcf that's why i'm
not doing that
well okay um
let's show all files
uh what's not included in the project
oh i found that i could can i uh what's
the expand where's the expandable thing
class collapse all is there
the opposite of that no okay
source
uh
no enough source external free type
let's include it in project uh let's get
rid of all the files we don't need maybe
well that's taking a while
that's taking a while
okay let's just build it
okay
what's where's this at
static function in inflate co y is so
this is what now inflate what what is
this in
gzip do we need gzip maybe we just don't
need it
gzip
exclude let's see what happens
then
it doesn't look like it okay cool so
let's um go back to our includes
ah this is going to this is annoying
uh that stuff i think we've already done
we've already already dealt with that
um okay
oh here we go oh so much oh my goodness
ah okay
goodbye
goodbye
well if it says end end of what and it
is end of destruction
okay uh there's more
obviously
of course it's more
ah yes
more
there's more
59 errors that's slow
ish
there should be a macro being like do
not include c files
that would be good if they did that that
would be fantastic
i'm not sure why i'm not sure
really why they would have done it
anyway it doesn't seem
unnecessary
no there's just so many of them
goodness me i need to write a tool
that
just basically goes through everything
and if it's
and include i've got a better idea
that's not what i'm at
let's see
there we go
uh that is not what i was looking for
what
let's not do that
there we go
um okay good so this is probably better
yep
best episode of sparky yet i'm alright
oh but wait there's more
holy guacamole
is all i can say
um
can i tell visual studio to look through
only uncommented code because that would
be nice
wow a single line one
rare
let's just build this and see what
happens
32 errors
oh my goodness
well you guys wanted to see all of
sparky so here you go
best
this whole thing shouldn't be a thing
22.
i'm probably skipping a bunch of stuff i
shouldn't be as well
yeah that's not what i want i don't want
to see the vc project stuff
okay so that's it apparently um okay so
let's go through this again because i
skipped half of it because i was a bit
upset
see some of this might actually be
useful though some of this might
actually need to exist because it
includes other stuff but no it doesn't
because it's being compiled
so i guess the idea of why they did this
was because they're like oh you only
need to compile these files but see the
problem with that is i don't know which
files i should be compiling because they
should have used macros and whatnot but
i'm really surprised there's nothing
like that
so it's going to be just annoying
is there a way to not search comments
as if that's not a thing
someone would have written a plugin for
that
okay um
how many errors are we getting at this
point
20.
see we should just not compile this
stuff basically or like not compile any
of these but the thing is that's just
not a thing it's compiling both of them
ah
true type
i should just delete this
there's going to be a time where i
actually go through this and i fix it as
in like i get rid of um
oh my goodness
fudge factory
goodbye comments
there's going to be a time when i go
through this and i actually just remove
the files i'll probably more simply just
remove a lot of this compilation stuff
that that would be good it's just that i
just it's just going to take too long
because there aren't macros well they
should be
so to my understanding the reason
they've done this is just so that you
don't have a million obj files it just
compiles one but it like it kind of it
combines multiple c plus c multiple c
files into one and then compile that one
file instead of compiling a lot of a lot
of different files but the problem is
it's compiling both the
individual ones and the group of them
which is why we're getting duplicate
symbols
but um
uh i would have expected and maybe i'm
wrong maybe there is some macro that
hides this stuff but
it's not evident at all in fact there
probably is because
it compiles it somehow
there has to be i'm probably just missed
it but i'm not in the mood to go
macro hunting after we've spent so much
time doing this
look at this sneaky one
out
don't include c files
uh honestly just you just you shouldn't
include c files like ever unless you
have very strict macros that
are documented well they probably are
documented well it's probably just my
fault for not reading the documentation
to be honest so i'm not gonna be too
harsh or anything
okay i think
there's
okay so we've got how many errors now
six okay here we go we've got four
unresolved excels oh okay they're on
resolving channels mains already defined
uh that's okay um in apparently gv what
so these are missing things now
uh
and where
in
in
g
gen
what the fridge
let's just exclude that
oh what's that
yeah so that was um
that let's get rid of that
okay uh
we're not this is not a thing
should it be though
it's only got one file actually so let's
let's include that
oh which probably doesn't have one file
uh i'm just searching for it lol
okay it's got a lot of files
um let's build this again
uh
yeah
let's get rid of that
okay so
uh water fit yes so autofit was
something that i didn't
grab
so really we needed everything oh my
goodness i'm annoyed at myself to be
honest
include
and we'll just get rid of
this stuff um it's not really necessary
to do that because i could just go for a
find all and whatnot and actually just
remove them
all at once i'd probably be wise
okay this is interesting um
what's this ft advances do we need that
ft advances h let's take a look at where
that's at so that's in
a flat in
in auto
a flat in huh
no not found what's going on
wait
what
these are all the files it needs
oh my goodness it probably is oh
really
really
this is all you need
i should have just fudging compiled that
no
it's probably not because it includes a
bunch of stuff i bet
yes it does
so these are all the files that needed
to be compiled everything else should
have been there
though okay here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna do this this is the sensible
way of doing it we need everything in
our directory we need everything set up
well and these things
like bdf lib for example how is how on
earth is that going to unless it's just
referenced it is
so these are the only files we need to
compile everything else
shouldn't exist basically as far as
we're concerned
and they're all as you can see they're
all linked
smartly linked
so
there are a lot of them though
oh
let's just do it let's just do it let's
just do this once and for all then we
won't have to touch it ever again
um
i cannot believe i'm about to do this
but i'm totally about to do this um
let's uh
basically
just
exclude everything
this is so ridiculous
no but then i've oh [ __ ]
i'm i'm not happy i guess you can't tell
but we're doing it because
i should have done this from the
beginning
so everything is getting i should have
definitely looked at this more closely
so it's completely my bad so i'm just
going to put this on my second monitor
i'm going to go through each of these
files and i'm only going to include the
ones we need let's refresh this
okay so
out of here in source in fact i don't
even have to do like any of this
like
i could put free type into my
dependencies
so not this one we can get rid of this
now
not this one i could put this into my
dependencies
oh well doesn't matter let's okay we're
quickly doing this i promise
um
okay so let's get rid of show all files
uh under source files i'm going to make
a new folder a new filter whatever we
want to call it
called
ext
and there's going to be a new filter
called
free type
and then it doesn't really matter how
you split this i'm going to basically
copy what they've done so they've got um
and they've got the same thing on the
header as well
why why what
why is that still thing
what
what
what
oh i didn't sorry i almost freaked the
freak out there exclude
okay better
new filter um
ext
i should have just oh man so many
problems and i'm
a bit annoying
um but now you know what it's like to
compare libraries and hopefully you will
learn a lot from this video such as
maybe you should pay attention to the
actual project setup before you attempt
to compile your own
picture library by yourself um ext free
type
okay so here's what we're doing we're
going to hit right click add existing
item
we're going to go into ext free type and
source we're going to
look at all of these header files that
are over here okay and we're going to
include them and we're going to add them
as
what
where's little button to add them as a
link
or maybe once i click on it it appears
it better
and then we're going to add them as
links so it's not actually going to yes
you'll see it's going to be good so ftf2
whatever build thing
dot h
are you kidding me
just show me the file
are you apps are you high
this was supposed to be so smooth
i guess i didn't find the file because
it's probably in like include yes it's
here
how do i add this thing as a link
why is there no in windows 7 there's
like a little
oh my goodness
i might have to google this
so
from the open button drop down list
select add as link
gee thanks
maybe it only works for
or maybe i don't need yeah okay
maybe i don't need out of link if it's
ziploc boss i could be a
good thing oh i guess i don't need
headers
ugh
let's just do this
um existing item okay let's just add the
keyboard file first this is
it's great um
okay so uh
autofit let's begin with that one
autofit
okay
good so it is yeah
hmm i'm still kind of skeptical but
we'll just we'll keep going
i'm going to put this on my other
monitor
longest episode of sparky ever and it's
not even that good
cff
ft base
we're going to need the h as well
no i think we are
oh no we don't
ah
so much fun
ft bitmap
ft cash
i forgot to back out
cool
um
i feel like we need some music or
something
because this is going to be boring
and it's 10 o'clock
f t f s type
there you are
ft
gasp
like halfway through the uh non modules
fd glyph
ft
gzip
looks like we did need that
or at least it wanted us to believe that
we did
ft init
let's try that again
ft init
ft lzw
oh i did the thing again
ft stroke
ft system
i feel the need to announce each of
these files at length by the way and the
last one is just not ft it's just it's
just smooth
smooth
okay let's just compile oh no that's
right i
need the fudging modules
ft modules
oh there's so many of them goodness me
ft box
not in smooth
ft blocks
ft gx val
ft lcd fill basically guys don't use
inscription and compile this as a static
library and rejoice but you know we're
going the
the hard work root
because of
our beloved ms krypton
um
f t o t val
f t
patent
or patent depending on how you want to
pronounce that
exciting
ft pfr
i just realized i probably could have
just copied the xml
changed a few things and i would have
everything
why did no one in the in the stream
tell me that
too late now
oh i should have just totally done that
what was the last thing i included
that thing
ft synth oh yes gotta have those
synthesizers
this is kind of relaxing says my chat
good
the great thing is you don't need to be
an amazing programmer to do this
so
this should be one of the easier parts
of making this sparky engine but one of
the more boring
parts
um ft win did i already do that one
oh
oh look at me
i think there's anything twice
ftxf86
no no get out yes die bye
uh
pcf
pcr i think it's in the same folder
i'm wrong
predictably
ah
ps pfr
free type you library you
um
peace oh
sure
if anyone goes through this video and
actually follows it along click button
click and like goes through the whole
pausing thing they're going to
they're going to not have a good time
this is this is one of those videos
where you should just go to github and
just take the visual studio project file
i'll i'll allow it even though i'm all
for copying things yourself instead of
actually
um
instead of actually uh
just cop like copying and pasting but
actually taking this stuff down and
doing it yourself since you learned it
this is just nothing to learn here
the things to learn here are my mistakes
in getting this to work so i hope this
will this is going to serve as one of
those
like videos like a reflection video
about everything that's wrong with me
and how i should have definitely paid
more attention to how free type was set
up
um rather than oh just just this video
man just this video
just this freaking
video i might actually just speed up the
video that would be cheating though i
want everyone to watch this i want
everyone to what i want i want this to
serve as an internal reminder
of how you should uh
not do any of what i just did
this wouldn't even be a problem if oh
this is is that it let's just let's just
see what happens
okay well apparently it's not it because
autofit is annoying i must have missed
something
let's go through it
said journal let's go through it
autofit check pdf check
cff present
ft base check bitmap check cache debug
stipe
gasp glyph
gzip init zw
ft stroke
synth
oh we're missing no not
wait
no i'm not missing anything i just i
can't read ah stroke system
wait synth
was synth supposed to be in modules
ah it was so
error not that it matters but
i want to make it the same obviously
system and smooth okay that's all
present so did i miss the module
box gx val
this thing
mm
ot val
patent
pfr
synth
type one
win fnt
that 86 thing pcf
pfr
p shocks
ps hinter
ps module rasta this is annoying as a
true type type one
they're all here
cid type 42
and when oh my goodness well
so
almost intellisense errors
no
why are these unresolved
have i forgotten something
unless the headers include
stuff
ugh let's add the headers just because
they should be in our project let's save
our project imagine like if my computer
just crashed and all that work was for
nothing oh man
okay uh headers um
so we need f2t again this won't actually
this shouldn't actually matter but i do
want them to be part of the project
f2 this is slightly easier and by
slightly i mean a lot easier because
there's like there's like six of them
um
ft header
uh ft module
am i recording this
sadly yes
um
ft option
because i i would not have been mad if i
looked
at the thing and it wasn't recording
honestly i would have been like lol okay
ftsd lib
such a comedy video this
okay
so now we
oh my goodness
it's
okay that's that's all there
i'm not going to go through that list
at all
um
yes so source files
they're all they're all freaking here
why are you not being compiled you
naughty source files
what is it missing
do i still have some weird thing
included
unresolved external symbol ft get next
char
that's yeah well our one intel sensor
let's just rebuild
those warnings though
where they're out but let's just pop
this back here i think
clean
build
blinking
yay
okay so it needed to clean because it
had a bunch of stuff that didn't that
wasn't cool
okay we have successfully built free
type
yes
so um
that's
i mean i'm amazed personally that we did
this
and
yes
um
the best thing ever
let's go ahead and just do free type gl
right now because uh we might as well
keep it in this video because since this
is the comedy video
so free type gl if we just head over
there we can go to the github repository
uh you can clone this yourself if you
want you can just download the zip file
that's probably easier
and here we have it just on github
so again i'll i'll keep this in ext and
i'll make a
free type
gl
and
a
uh
do the same for headers
free type
gl and i should set up a folder
hierarchy for all these obviously but
we'll get around to that eventually um
so there's the gl master thing from this
again
uh
you'll probably need a bunch of stuff we
are not too concerned with um most of
this to be honest if i
were to compile this for us
um
we can try to do something with this we
could probably just make sure that it
works somewhat
let's take a look at we don't we don't
need most of this let's um that's what i
said about pre-type gl as well but i
actually mean it
sorry that's what i said about free time
but i actually mean it for free type gl
so we don't need most of this
great okay let's um copy this stuff
uh okay so we only need um
like this stuff honestly let's just cut
like this
um
so interfere type gl i'm going to put
just i want to dump this stuff here
um yeah it's got much fonts we don't
care doc starter
docs
delete um
yeah we don't need anything else so
let's delete that see you make lists
goodbye watch the demos we don't need
but we don't need any of these demos
i'll keep the font one just purely
because that's got some useful code in
it that we'll take a look at we don't
need arial i think
oh well that's the actual font
um we don't need that we've got real
fonts um
oh that could be good as a fallback font
actually i'll leave that thing there
read me goodbye
read you
uh to do goodbye um
this stuff
out of here we don't need most of this
stuff we'll filter it in a minute so if
i go to free type gl i go add existing
item and we go to free type gl
and we add like all this stuff it'll
just
add it into the appropriate
not worried
it'll just totally add the c files into
the what
can i control said that
why would you add the c files into the
header section are you
kidding me
i thought it would just work but
apparently
okay
well guess i'm going through all these
files and getting rid of them
i didn't know it would allow me to do
that
maybe it'll treat them as headers and
not compile them i'm guessing it well
uh no
let's not delete the actual files
uh again we don't need stuff like vec3
we'll um we'll do we'll deal with this
in fact we might change it a bit to use
our math library but we'll see that
might be a bit extreme because our mass
library is not complete so let's solve
this by type and just grab the c files
okay so again demo font isn't really
needed um
let's uh
where what's this okay
yes so it's not really needed um
let's exclude that because otherwise
it's going to yell about compilation
problems let's just build this and
we'll deal with all the errors so a lot
of this stuff is okay so it's over glut
we don't need that
what's that in make font so make font is
actually also a demo we don't want that
they're all all the demos have a demo
preview because if except for make font
that doesn't so let's exclude that
okay okay fantastic so all the errors we
get are now
for stuff like stuff that's deprecated
so let's just quickly google the
uh
so what is that uh
c4996
there's a macro that you can define it's
this one
that um we'll get rid of that
so
pre-processor for all configurations
oh
oh no that's actually not it that's
actually not it
no it's not we've got the security ones
that's not it um
it is
yes sdk check i don't think that will
yeah that won't actually get rid of it
until specific one is there's a macro
there's a pre-processor does the depth
fine
to get rid of it
it's not that
ah is this one no deprecate
i found it all good in the hood
okay so this should um
get rid of those errors
what else
oh what what is it
that totally seems legit maybe it's not
that one maybe that guy lied he was
asking how to use it so maybe he's got
no clue
there's some kind of no dip no deprecate
thing though
no
no deprecate is that actually it
crt secure no deprecate
um
walls
let me just see if i can find what it's
called
um
ah here it is it's crt non
that thing i don't know i pulled it out
of another project of mine
that is what it is crt non
stdc no deprecate so
build that and we shouldn't get any
problems
okay
the best
okay
okay that's fine so text buffer uses
shader load for some reason let's get
rid of that
so what is it's a text buffer what does
that do do we need that
it doesn't look like we do let's exclude
that
we might find that we do need it let's
just build this again
and see if we've got any problems okay
good so the build succeeded that's
that's step one um let's go into here
and see so matt4
i think we can safely exclude that
um
i don't think we actually need that font
manager i don't think we need that
either
there there is honestly there are let's
just get rid of um i'll print class for
you a lot oh yeah
um there's there aren't too many things
we actually need vector i believe we
probably will need that
because it uses it internally unless we
want to use our thing i don't really
want to refactor everything vertex
buffer we definitely don't need
because we have a vertex array i can
just get rid of here
all these headers for vectors and
whatever unfortunately they'll probably
collide
they're hours whoops effect 234 is what
i meant
they might collide with our namespaces
though
so i might have to add in a special
namespace for that
make sure people don't use that i don't
think they will though but it doesn't
look like it and it is in an ft uh gl
namespace so
let's get rid of vertex
but for vertex attribute we can get rid
of
vector will keep texture font
shader will definitely get rid of
shader
whoa
goodbye platform sounds important
hmm
yeah
that that it will need that
uh free type gl yes font manager we can
get rid of that i don't what's this
thing
this is
important um probably not
let's see if is this is that actually in
use anywhere
so
that should be enough
no it's not
so we'll get rid of that
so we're basically cleaning and i'm
going to just delete the files that we
don't need so
um
phone manager can just stop appearing in
places
markup
i don't think we need that
well we'll see
okay um platform that yeah we need that
dasher font yeah okay everything else we
are vertex has to be what i mean so
really all we need is like texture font
and texture atlas um
it does sound like we probably want
glyphs though did we delete them or were
they are they somewhere else
where are my glyphs at
hmm
where are glyphs in
because i know that that's important
yeah it looks like um that's free type
actually free wgl
yeah so texture glyph where's that at
okay so that's in texture font okay good
so we it looks like we've got everything
uh ariel 16
so
i think they've just gone ahead and
we'll get rid of that we don't need that
honestly
i was going to keep it but no
opengl it needs that platformer needs
that this stuff it needs all of it okay
good so we've reduced it to basically
for 4c files so that's amazing
um
let's go through and delete everything
that isn't that now so type i'll sort to
this um
we'll go through we only need so
platform is the first thing uh sorry
this is yeah platform is the first thing
we need here
uh shader we don't need
uh so texture atlas and font we do need
and then vector c is the only other
thing we need that can die
okay up here
uh we just need free type gl that's the
first one we need
um and then all the way to opengl
well
platform shader we don't need texture
atlas we
do
and then the backs and that's it okay
great so let's build
good so there we go
we've finally gotten
free type gl and uh
other stuff and free type to build
properly it looks like we've trimmed it
pretty heavily
everything looks pretty good there's a
lot of files that we added um i'm
probably going to go in here and there
are some files that don't have um like
all this stuff we don't need that i
don't want to commit that into into our
repository so i'm going to go through
this and i'm just going to make you guys
watch honestly i'm not going to pause
the video whatever there are certain
things that we just do not need um
what was that cn thing is that
is that important
what does that no that's probably a mac
a mac thing or something yeah we'll keep
that that sounds um
i don't know if we need that
what's the dat file is that just binary
no it's not
what is this does anyone know what this
is
well it's called like asian characters
i don't know if this is required
i'll keep it for now
because it looks suspicious
uh type
so i'm just going to search for jam file
and get rid of all the jam files
not ft option though that's like in
there
uh what was the other one
dot mk so anything that's a dot mk can
also go away
rules dot mk i follow no rules
um
all right so this is probably that's
probably it i don't think there's
yeah everything else is just going to
just randomly check a few of these
oh huh python
well
well
we don't want any of that
what is that even for these scripts a
lot these are the tools so we'll get rid
of tools we don't need that
we don't need any tools
well right mace we'll get rid of red
maze as well
um yes
i'm just checking for any files that we
probably don't want
this is better because we haven't
actually modified free type source code
i like this more okay we've kept those
things for no apparent reason um
okay great so
we're done so i'm going to commit this
um
i think a few people were interested in
how i'm managing the github repository
and whatnot so i'll quickly i'll do a
commit on video here for you so if we go
to our projects and we
i'm using something called tortoise git
um there's other things you can use
uh you can just use command line git i
find it's a bit easier to use total skin
and i'll show you why if you go to
twitter skit and um let's just say your
the good thing about this is it has
stuff like tortoise merch so if i've
edited a file such as like
main and i'm i want to see
how it's changed i can go ahead and just
view the diff okay right now uh there is
no diff because um i haven't made any
changes to it but if i was to say add
another text id i could view the diff of
that file
via tortoise get and i could be like oh
look i've added 10 and you can see what
you've added in one month so it's very
very useful
um and you can see that a good example
is probably this thing because i've
added a lot here if i look at the
different here you can see i've added
all these files okay and that's what's
changed about this particular file so
it's nice and it's just it just gives
you an interface forget for command line
get right and it gives you a lot of cool
tools like you know revert and whatnot
and
um
and blame okay the blame will probably
will just all be me but
the cherno everywhere
but um it's a yeah it's it's i guess
that's more useful when you're working
with teams so you can be like oh this
person wrote this line of code
i want to go talk to them
about what they've done um but
yes so let's uh and then you can you see
that like change there i can just be
like oh let's revert this back to well
yeah back to that you can see here that
the 10 is gone so anyway it's
nice to use so if i was committing
something i could just be like
uh git commit
and then it will bring up this thing so
there's a lot of files here that i don't
want to commit um these are the files
that have changed so let's uh i don't
think i'll be able to build it as a
debug anymore actually i probably should
be like wrap up this episode let's just
make sure it builds as a d as let's just
make sure debug builds still
because um i've got a suspicion that it
won't it might
no
okay potentially okay that's the end
okay so let's turn off stuff like sdl
checks and a few security things in
debug
so if we go into so sdl checks we can
just shut off
um
and we'll see if that fixes that
unfortunately my compilation time is
going to be much higher now but um there
you go so that did it um
even though it's on for release that's
interesting
we should turn it off for release
anyway uh so debug is now good uh let's
do that and let's build release as well
not to mention now exe
is probably much bigger now than it was
let's just take a look at debug
it's over a megabyte
nice
anyway um
yes so i do i do commit the executables
by the way and other binary stuff
um but if we go to commit again
these are all good now um so i don't do
this stuff and then i just pick
everything i want so this i think from
this onwards ah things like that is so
many files
so i want to add all of this so i'll
select all of it and just go right click
add not export selection add
see how long it's taking to add all of
them this is going to be the biggest
push ever but it's got the entire free
type so this is going to be
episode
18 i believe
uh
free type and free type
gl
so how do they style that
probably not the way i'm styling it um
i don't really care because it's gonna
be uppercase anyway but
how does free type style itself
okay free type i see
free type so i guess this should be free
type gl
even though they've
i think free type gl have decided to
style themselves differently
maybe
i don't know so they've misspelled free
type basically well they haven't
misspelled it but that should be capital
so i'll just do free type gl like that
okay free time and free type gl
and then i can just hit okay
and then i can push it straight away so
yeah and that's the plan that's the
master plan so that's how i use tortoise
get to manage this sparky stuff
um
like i just have to log in and it will
push everything and everything will be
the best so 504 files
wow okay it's tons it's huge it's a lot
but um we've now got all that stuff
working
okay so next episode we're going to
um look at how we can actually use free
type and free type gl to load in fonts
and basically use them together with our
renderer with our batch renderer so that
we can render fonts using that okay and
that should be a fairly long episode as
well i'm guessing it'll take about an
hour or so but um
uh yeah but we'll have font rendering in
the bag um
like you know together with shaders and
all of that all that stuff so that's the
master plan
um if you guys enjoyed this video please
hit the like button and i'll see you
guys next time goodbye
you